I was gonna say there's something about
what's in the water in Detroit right now
between yourself we talked about cash
kid baby Tron just these like great
one-liners that you're just like oh [__]
or it's like especially with the sports
bars and [__] like there's something
about the sports bars that you have that
cash kids got that baby trans guy were
just like Jesus they kind of got a no to
know like random NBA references and [__]
like
what's your favorite
bar you have in your phone right now
that you've written recently give me a
line give me a one line that you just
you just wrote recently you're like oh
when people hear this
uh
my my new way I kill people I let them
live oh
I like that that's deep yeah I said I
found a new way to kill people I just
let them live
I look forward to uh well I don't look
forward to it but you know what's coming
there's gonna be so many people making
these Titanic submarine bars in the next
like two weeks
I don't wanna I don't want to make fun
of the people no they died I feel like
it's [__] up what's happening because
it's like a lot of people lost their
life and it's become like a joke online
I think um
there's no sense around people in the
world no more and that's a big deal like
that that's a big deal to me like people
making fun of people dying and stuff
that's not like when you do it in your
own household or something it's cool
like but why put that into the world for
the world to consume why add to that
people like laughing at negative stuff
like going online and trying to say the
most negative stuff possible is not
funny to me how do you try to disconnect
from like reading comments or like
paying too much attention to some of the
online [__] because I used to not read
them like I used to not read them and
not just because they're negative it's
just be like I don't want to get caught
up and I know Fame is a drug like when
you hire you hide when you love you low
but I read them not and I laugh at them
I do all because I I I know myself I'm
strong enough not to care I don't care
you don't think subconsciously it might
somehow like be up there not because I
um I know how to decipher
um fact from fiction so it'd be like if
you say this I know this ain't true and
if you say this I know it is true so you
do got the right to say that because
it's true and then it just be like I use
a lot of it for motivation or like
um I like I'm I'm my biggest critic so
I'll just be wanting to see what people
do and don't like about me so do you
feel like because I feel like you've
improved immensely over the last few
years just as an artist as a rapper
um
do you ever go back and listen to like
stuff or hear stuff that's like maybe a
few years old and be like damn I was
like I'm so much better now like I swear
I listen to a lot of stuff and my voice
be like like you like you say I got
bigger and stuff and then my voice used
to crack and I used to be like sounding
like a real little kid so yeah I was
listening somebody was telling me a song
that I made a few years ago and I was
telling them like man I sound like a kid
it was trash for sure I do that all the
time how uh important is it for you to
keep like pushing yourself as a as an
emcee because you care about I feel like
you you're a high level rapper you know
what I'm saying I talked to Chris Brown
one time like a couple weeks ago I was
at his rehearsal with TM I asked him
like how do you stay grounded and you
told me I act like I didn't accomplish
nothing so I think that's Mo that's most
important you act like you just like my
coaches to tell me when I get in the end
zone act like I've been there before so
I just act like I don't do nothing
that's the biggest thing that a lot of
somebody didn't told me in a while Chris
Brown told me that I act like he act
like he don't haven't accomplished
anything because if you let uh if you
let your recent [__] get to your head
you're gonna get lazy get lazy yeah get
complacent complacency is the worst [__]
ever man yeah Chris that's a nice just
hanging with Chris Brown see a fan I
don't think he's a fan not yet he is he
remembered me from when I met him with
Sada a few years ago that's one of the
most humblest people I've met
um from my experience she was at my top
two celebrities I ever met was G herbo
and Chris Brown for real and you work
with G herbo yeah what was that like it
was cool as hell like we also like the
nicest guy ever that's what it got the
most humble cool [__] alive like
he he recorded a lot of his album from
like a couple years ago in the mild
Studio that you recorded at she here was
the best I swear to God I I like I love
him like a brother I I just met him a
few months ago like he like he just
wanted a nicest humblest people like you
said and he's like one of the most like
emotionally wise artists I've ever met
like he's very self-aware he's aware of
like what he says how it can affect [__]
and like super man I love I love G for
sure he's a great guy
um
what's coming I mean obviously the
deluxe just dropped but I I you already
know you got to have another album in
the pipeline yeah I'm trying to drop an
album um in August or September
um I'm just working on making a meal I
want this when I do this album I want it
to be like the best music I ever put out
like I got a few records that I know
gonna go and then I'm just working a
field in some record slot I know like on
a mixtape it could be like some people
might not like this some people might
like this everybody like this I want
every song to be at like that it's
non-stop no skips gotta have no skips
for sure